اعلنت هيئته شؤون الاسرى والمحررين
الفلسطينيه استشهاد الاسير ناصر ابو حميد
في مستشفى اساف هارو في الاسرائيلي نتيجه
تدهور حالته الصحيه للراعي اصابته بسرطان
الرئه منذ اكثر من عام
وحملت الهيئه حكومه الاحتلال المسؤوليه
الكامله عن وفاته بسبب ما وصفته بسياسه
القتل الطبي المتعمد التي تتبعها اداره
سجون الاحتلال بحق الاسرار هذا وقال مراسل
الجزيره ان اضراب عاما وفد في مدن
فلسطينيه عده
كافه جوانب الحياه العامه والرسميه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه بما فيها
القدس المحتله
انضم الينا من مخيم الامعري في رام الله
مراسل الجزيره سمير ابو شماره سمير معنا
تضعنا في سوره المشهد العام وردود الفعل
على وفاه الشهيد
قباله المدخل الرئيس لمخيم الامعري
للاجئين في وسط مدينه رام الله حيث يتجمع
عدد من الشبان الفلسطينيين عند هذا المدخل
في حاله من الحزن والحداد على استشهاد
الاسير ناصر ابو حميد وهو من سكان مخيم
الامعري واحد قيادات
البارزه في داخل المخيم التابعه لحركه
فتحه لحركه الاسيره همم الاعلان عن
استشهاد الاسير ابو حميد هو كان صدمه
للشارع عن فلسطين ولكنها كانت صدمه متوقعه
مع تعنته الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لافراج عنه
رغم تدهور حالته الصحيه بشكل كبير حيث تم
نقله يوم امس الى مستشفى سافروا في جنوبيه
تل ابيب وذلك بعد ان ترى عليه تدهور عاجل
وشكل طارق على ودخل في غيبوبه كامله ولكن
عائلته التي حرمت لفتره طويله من زيارته
ورؤيته كان هناك تنسيق من قبل هيئه الشؤون
المدنيه وايضا اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر لزيارته حيث كان في زيارته 22قانه
ووالدته التي قرات بعض الايات القرانيه
عليه قبل ان تودعه وتغادره مساء يوم امس
ولكن في صباح هذا اليوم اعلنت هيئه شؤون
الاسرى والمحررين استشهاد الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد وهو الذي كان محكوم في السجون
الاسرائيليه سبع مؤبدات وايضا 50 عاما
وذلك همم لقتله سبعه استراليين بينهم ضابط
خلال فتره الانتفاضه السابقه وكان قد ايه
الشهيد ناصر ابو حميد اكثر من 30 عاما
مجموعه اكثر من 30 عاما في سجون الاحتلال
الايطاليه كان منها 22 عاما بشكل متواصل
حيث تم اعت في العام
الماضي الاسير ناصر ابو حميد هو احد
الخيازات البارزه في حركه فتح وجناحي
العسكري وايضا كان حسب المصادر المحليه
كان يطلق عليه الاسد المقنع وايضا كان هو
الذي قد اطلق اول قذيفه على الجانب
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه وايضا قتل
سبعه اصليين خلال هجمات وعمليات اطلاق نار
على اسرائيليين وبالتالي الان هناك حاله
حداد واضراب شامل في جميع المناطق
الفلسطينيه والمحافظات الفلسطينيه وايضا
بما في ذلك المدارس التي اعلنت عن تعطيل
الدراسه بعد الحصه الثالثه وايضا المؤسسات
العامه والخاصه قد اغلقت ابوابها امام
الموظفين وذلك حدادا على روح الشهيد ناصر
ابو حميد الذي هو باستشهادي يرتفع عدد
شهداء الحركه الاسيره في سجون الاحتلال
الى 200 و 33 شهيدا منهم 74 شهيدا همم
استشهدوا بجراه سياسه الاهمال الطبيه
المتعمده التي تمارسها اداره سجون
الاحتلال ضد الاسرى الفلسطينيين وتحديدا
ضد اكثر من 600 مريض من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين يعانون من امراض مزمنه او
مزمنه واورام داخل المعتقلات في ظل هذه
السياسه المنهجه من قبل سلطات الاحتلال
حسب المؤسسات الحقوقيه والرسميه عن
الفلسطينيه التي اكدت بان اسرائيل تمارس
هذه السياسه بشكل متعمد ولا توفر العلاج
المناسب والكامل الاسرى الفلسطينيين
المرضى الذين يقنعون داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه هناك محاولات من قبل المؤسسه
الرسميه وتحديدا من قبل امين سر اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين
الشيخ بصفاته ايضا وزير الشؤون المدنيه
باصلاته مع المؤسسات الدوليه والجانب
الاسرائيلي وذلك من اجل تسليم لقمان
الاسير ناصر ابو حميد الى ذويه لمرته ترى
في داخل مقبره الشهداء في مدينه رام الله
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه جهود ما زالت تبذل من
قبل الجهات الرسميه ولكن الجاي من جانب
للصليب لم يرد بالموافقه على تسليم الجي
جثمانه شهيد ناصر ابو حميد وهو بالتالي
سيكون الشهيد رقم 11 وهو من الشهداء من
حركه الاسئله التي المحتجزه لدى قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيل الاسرائيلي عفوا شكرا
جزيلا الله معرفه